>> Greg: DO YOUR ANGRY BOSSES
SCREAMS SHOW UP IN YOUR DREAMS.
ACCORDING TO THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" OWNED BY OUR PARENT
COMPANY, DREAMS ABOUT WORK ARE
RUINING PEOPLE'S NIGHT TIME
HOURS.
THE NIGHTMARE WHERE JESSE
WATTERS HOSTS THIS SHOW.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: SHOWING UP TO A MEETING
WITHOUT PANTS ON AND MISSING
YOUR FLIGHT AND FORGETTING
A DEADLINE UNTIL IT'S PAST ARE
COMMON DREAM THEMES.
OR FOR KAT REAL THINGS THAT
HAPPENED.
EXPERTS SAYING DREAMING ABOUT
WORK GIVES US INSIGHT IN TO HOW
WHO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
COULD THAT BE TRUE?
>> WHAT A LONG DAY.
[SIGHING].
>> ♪ ♪
>> HI, CAT?
>> GREG WOULD YOU LIKE THIS CUP
OF POISON?
>> THAT'S ODD.
I WONDER IF I AM IN SOMEBODY'S
DREAM.
IT TASTES PRETTY GOOD.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: KAT, DO YOU HAVE DREAMS
LIKE THAT?
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOUR WORK
DREAMS?
>> I DON'T HAVE WORK DREAMS.
I AM TRYING TO THINK.
I GET REALLY WEIRD DREAMS.
I THINK WHAT IS APPROPRIATE AND
WON'T GET ME FIRED IF I TALK
ABOUT IT.
I GET DREAMS THAT MY HUSBAND
CHEATS ON ME AND I GET MAD AT
HIM AND I START THE GROUP CHAT
WITH MY SISTER.
YOU WERE IN MY DREAM LAST NIGHT.
SHE SAID APOLOGIZE AND HE
DOESN'T.
WE ARE 5 MONTHS IN AND THINGS
ARE GOING WELL.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: TYRUS YOU HAVE MANY
DIFFERENT JOBS.
DO YOU HAVE A DREAM WHERE THEY
ARE COMBINED?
YOU SHOW UP TO WRESTLE BUT YOU
ARE SITTING AND HAVE TO DO
COMMENTARY?
>> NO, GREG, MAYBE IT'S
A CULTURE THING.
I ONLY HAVE BAD DREAMS WHEN I
DON'T HAVE CHECKS COMING IN.
THE ONLY TIME I HAVE BAD DREAMS
WHEN CHILD SUPPORT IS DUE AND I
HAVE NOTHING COMING IN.
THAT'S A BAD DREAM.
I GOT THE THIRD RED NOTICE WITH
CANCELLATION DATES TOMORROW AND
TRYING TO TRICK THE ELECTRIC
COMPANY TO EXTEND IT FOR 2
WEEKS.
THOSE ARE THE DREAMS IN MY
LIFETIME.
I NEVER HAD OH I AM SO GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED.
I SHOWED UP TO WORK AND SAT IN
A CHAIR AND PAID A LOT OF MONEY
TO GIVE MY OPINION.
WHAT DO I DO?
>> Greg: THIS IS ANOTHER WHITE
MAN PROBLEM?
>> NO, BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT OF
BROKE WHITE FRIENDS.
IT'S A FIRST WORLD PROBLEM.
THIS IS STUPID STUFF THAT WE
WILL CALL THEM JOURNALISTS HAVE
NOTHING ON THE TABLE.
WHAT HAVE WE GOT?
ANYONE GOT A BAD DREAM ABOUT
HAVING A JOB.
THAT'S LIKE TELLING SOMEBODY
IT'S JUST HUNGER PAINS IN
CAMBODIO.
>> Greg: JESSE WATTERS SAID
TALKING ABOUT TALKING ABOUT YOUR
DREAMS MAKES YOU SOFT.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I ALSO HAVE WORK RELATED DREAMS
INVOLVING KAT'S HUSBAND.
WE DRIVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
KAT IS NOT INVITED.
I HAVE DREAMS ALL THE TIME WHERE
I HAVE TRAGEDIES AND SUCCESSES
AND THEN WAKE UP AND THINK WHY
CAN'T I WRITE ONE NOVEL?
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
THERE IS THE UNCHARTED DEPOSIT
IN YOUR BRAIN WITH PLOTS.
I WAKE UP IN THE MORNING AND
THEN IT'S FORGOTTEN.
THAT'S THE WEIRD THING ABOUT
DREAMS.
THEY ARE SO RICH.
YOUR MIND WON'T CLING TO IT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REAL, ROB.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HAD HAD A DREAM
WITH YOU WON THE LOTTERY AND YOU
WAKE UP SAD.
MAN, THAT WAS A DREAM.
THIS IS A FUNCTION OF PEOPLE
THAT WORK TOO MUCH.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK.
AS AMERICANS WE WORK TOO MUCH.
WE DON'T TAKE ENOUGH VACATIONS.
I AVOID THIS BY WORKING AS
LITTLE AS POSSIBLE.
I NEVER DREAM ABOUT WORK.
>> Greg: I TALKED ABOUT I DON'T
HAVE WORK DREAMS.
I HAVE HYGIENE.
I AM ALWAYS TRYING TO FIND
A TOILET.
THOSE ARE MY NIGHTMARES.
RUNNING THROUGH A WEIRD HOUSE
AND I GO TO EVERY BATHROOM AND
EVERY TOILET IS FILLED WITH
FILTH OR MISSING A TOILET SEAT.
>> OH, MAN.
>> Greg: I AM RUNNING AROUND.
>> I USED TO HAVE FOOTBALL
DREAMS WHERE I FORGOT MY HELMET
AND RUN ON THE FIELD.
YOUR ENTIRE LIFE, THE ONLY THING
YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT IS FINDING
A TOILET?
I THINK YOU HAVE HAD A GREAT
LIFE.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT IS LIKE.
YOU NEED A TOILET.
>> YOU REASON YOU CAN'T FIND
A TOILET IS BECAUSE YOU ARE
DREAMING?
>> Greg: NO, BECAUSE I WAKE UP
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO TO THE
BATHROOM.
>> AT THE END YOU FIND YOUR
TOILET?
>> Greg: IT WAS THERE ALL ALONG.
>> THERE IS YOUR NOVEL, JOE.
>> I CAN'T GET THIS IMAGE OF THE
TOILET FILLED OUT OF MY MIND.
>> Greg: DON'T GO AWAY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BAC